ragazzi so che in questo momento non
potete vedermi ma vi giuro che sono
proprio qui sulla sedia il fatto è che
sono diventato invisibile e vi racconto
secondo com'è andata è iniziato tutto in
modo particolare quando questa mattina
pensavo di essere ancora addormentato e
di stare sognando ma quando in realtà
non stavo per niente sognando e in quel
momento preciso ho pensato di non essere
mai esistito come se fossi stato l'amico
immaginario di 6 milioni di persone così
ho controllato se ci fossero i video su
youtube e per fortuna era tutto a posto
quindi alla fine esistevo e se fosse
esistito soltanto su youtube
facciamo una prova niente non va neanche
questa ed è in questo momento ragazzi
che ho veramente cominciato ad impari
karma quindi sono uscito di casa ho
corso ho corso ancora qui ho
attraversato la strada però piano perché
non c'è dalla disperazione ragazzi ho
provato a vedere se qualcuno riuscisse a
vedermi
scusi scusi scusi sono sono qui io sono
qui sono qui io non scappino scafi ogni
volta che provavo a palesarsi sembrava
una scena di paranormal activity quindi
ho dovuto chiedere aiuto a qualcuno
ecco e qualcuno e giampiero
però è chiamato bravo dove sai bagno
e quindi ragazzi sono ufficialmente
diventato invisibile non so neanche come
fare per risolvere la situazione che
cercherò di risolvere appunto in questi
giorni ma non ho idea di come fare e
comunque ragazzi il discorso è che
adesso che sono invisibile e ho
veramente capito che cosa significa
essere invisibile vi assicuro che
comunque non è una cosa bella
cioè nel senso non essere visti non mi
piace non spero veramente che finisca
presto questa situazione perché
purtroppo non è il massimo
a presto speriamo
[Musica]